welcome to our country okay my name is
okay
okay good good well i'm not used to that
but that's fine
if this car drive into a group of gypsy
will there be any damage to the car it
depends on how hard you hit them and all
that it's hard
welcome to your weekly ticket
sasha baron cohen has secretly shot and
screened borat 2.
according to collider cohen has already
filmed a sequel to the hit 2006 movie
the report suggests that some industry
members have already screened the film
cohen earned a golden globe award for
borat and the film's success at the box
office
paved the way for future characters and
movies like bruno the dictator and the
brothers grimsby
plot details of the sequel are still
vague and it's unclear when the film
will be released to the public
harry styles is returning to the big
screen three years after his feature
acting debut and christopher nolan's
dunkirk styles has landed his next role
in olivia wilde's don't worry darling
styles will be taking over for shia
labeouf who had to drop out due to
scheduling conflicts
wild's upcoming thriller will also star
florence pugh and chris pine who were
announced earlier this year
and jonathan magers is headed to the mcu
majors who's been turning heads with his
breakout performance in hbo's lovecraft
country has just landed a role in the
next
ant-man film he will play one of the
lead roles opposite paul rudd and
evangeline lilly
while plot details are being kept under
wraps in the quantum realm
magers is reportedly playing time
traveling super villain kang the
conqueror
the film will likely hit theaters in
2022
available to watch at home on friday is
lost girls and
love hotels fear and excitement are
chemically the same
sadness is a hair away from melancholy
melancholy is almost pleasure
rushing against happiness
it's all the same
[Music]
lost girls in love hotel is a
provocative journey inviting you to get
lost in japan
in hopes of experiencing fleeting
moments of beauty
the film follows the passionate tale of
love and lust between a haunted american
english teacher margaret
and a dashing yakuza named kazu as their
affair
tears them apart and reshapes them
across tokyo's landscape
of dive bars alleyways and three-hour
love hotels
and also available to watch at home on
friday is
antebellum
are you there
is anyone with you
can you get to a safe area
hello antebellum follows successful
author veronica henley played by janelle
monae who is forced to solve a
mind-bending mystery
when she finds herself trapped in a
horrifying reality
antebellum which is directed by gerard
busch and christopher rentz is produced
by ray mansfield and sean mckentrick the
same producers behind jordan peel's
social thrillers get out and
us alright that's it for today i'm kale
and i'll see you next time
you